i want to get reaction to that part from
bob woodson president and founder of the
woodson center bob we just discussed
with senator lee the attacks on our
fundamental institutions the democrats
claim they care about democracy and
process but in the end they obviously
want to tear most of this stuff down
how worrying is it that more americans
seem to believe less
in our founding the promise of liberty
and independence day itself
well it's devastating i know uh for more
vulnerable populations particularly on
the black community
um progressives are pushing this
anti-american agenda and using america's
birth defect of slavery as a bludgeon
against the country
one person even saying that she's as he
was going to celebrate juneteenth but
not 1776.
well she doesn't understand that if it
was not for 1776 there would be no
juneteenth
that uh
black americans have sacrificed has
demonstrated their commitment to these
values and ideals of ours
by the shedding of their bloods blacks
fought in every war that this country
has ever had
uh every war we fought and not a single
black was ever convicted of treason
um we have the harlem hell fighters my
dad was a member of that group the
tuskegee airmen and all these so america
people of color are risking their lives
to come here and enjoy the freedoms that
we enjoy
um and so we
we we should celebrate and we will
celebrate
well and a princeton professor had an
interesting take on independence day bob
watch
what are your thoughts uh
this going into this fourth of july
weekend on on pride and being an
american you know fourth of july has
always been an incredibly vexed
holiday for me
given the tradition out of which i come
it's framed by juneteenth the way in
which we struggle with the legacies of
slavery
he definitely just
doesn't want to teach
his students about the wonders of
liberty as
understood by generations and
generations
no and also i i just think they make
this this false claim that some of the
challenges of
of of
of
disadvantage in these cities around the
country the these disparities
are the caused by
uh racism and a history of slavery and
discrimination in fact laura
of the first 50 years after slavery
blacks actually in these cities fared
much better under segregation than they
have over the past 50 years of
progressive policies
children
we have five high schools in urban
centers
at the turn of the century
with
50 percent of the budgets of white
schools
used textbooks crumbling buildings yet
every one of those high schools scored
outs tested all white schools in the
cities in 1920 today in those same
school systems
the
blacks are achieving only 10 percent are
even efficient in schools today
when at the turn of the century under
segregation
bob happy independence day happy fourth
of july so great to see you as always
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else